a new show is opened in London
message in a bottle tells the story of
refugees three siblings fleeing their
village after it's bombed and held by
armed militia more I've researched and
gone into the more human side of the
story of refugees the more I've seen
that there's a way in art to try and
present it to provoke thought to maybe
humanize the situation a bit more to try
and help us approach people who've been
forced to flee their homeland with a bit
more kindness and a bit more
understanding the music is all sting
familiar songs that take on new
relevance putting words to grueling
experiences faced by millions
[Music]
message in a bottle was first released
40 years ago when sting was with his
band the police the songs of alienation
and isolation have been repurposed to
tell the story of refugees leaving their
homes and all they know for an uncharted
future hip hop popping locking breaking
contemporary dance at its most dynamic
the troupe of dancers from seven
countries also can snap into live
improvisation even the warm-up for the
dancers is physically demanding the show
involves changing styles varying speeds
early on in the process thing came to a
workshop he said he was moved by what he
saw and how the dancers had interpreted
its music using songs that already have
a fan base helps convince theater
producers that seats will be sold of
course from a commercial prerogative
having a back catalogue where people go
in knowing that they already know and
like the music that's a huge plus
ultimately this show is about human
resilience but not all refugee stories
end on an upbeat note the creator hopes
after seeing the moving portrayal of
people forced from their homes at least
London audiences will get the message
jessica baldwin al jazeera london